Before we jump into today's program very
quick correction yesterday during the
Trump NFL kerfuffle story we put a
picture up where Donald Trump appeared
to not have his hand over his heart
during the national anthem at a
Republican debate it appears that that
was a doctored picture so the analysis
remains but I do want to issue that
correction we may have been duped when
it came to the inclusion of that picture
okay we have a new version of the Donald
Trump travel ban and we can no longer
call it a majority Muslim country travel
ban it now has a new name I am now
calling it the punished countries Trump
doesn't like travel ban the initial
travel ban applied only to some Muslim
majority countries and that was
scheduled for hearing at the Supreme
Court this new version is no longer
scheduled for hearing at the Supreme
Court and it includes some non majority
Muslim countries wait a second what the
new Trump travel ban country lists is
Chad Iran Libya North Korea Somalia
Syria Venezuela and Yemen Iraq and Sudan
are gone from this new list this is just
the best the Trump defenders are saying
see the new list the fact that North
Korea is on there and they're mostly
atheist and Venezuela is on there and
they're mostly Catholic this proves it's
not about just banning Muslims the truth
is if this new list proves anything it's
that the list never was about keeping
America safe that's what we were told we
were told the list was about keeping
America safe we knew it really wasn't
because Saudi Arabia wasn't on the list
right that's an actual country that has
been the source of terrorists around the
world never on the list if you believe
in this type of travel ban how do you
justify not having Saudi Arabia on the
list but it's now 100% confirmed that
this is just a punitive list for
countries that Donald Trump doesn't like
let's start with Venezuela I am totally
against the Maduro regime and the faux
populist regime that has been in place
they are dating all the way back to Hugo
Chavez but if the idea is to keep
America's safe through this travel ban
how do you justify keeping people from
Venezuela out of the United States they
have one of the most legitimate cases to
come to the u.s. to flee the horrors of
what's going on in Venezuela what
evidence do we have that Venezuelan
people being in the United States is a
danger we have none
same situation with North Korea we don't
like the North Korean regime we don't
like the megalomaniac Kim jong-un but I
thought we wanted to help the North
Korean people right or is that not the
case North Koreans would be one of the
populations we would most expect to if
they could even find their way out of
North Korea right because it's pretty
tough to leave we would expect that
maybe they would come to the United
States as refugees legally whatever our
North Korean citizens known terrorists
do we have any reason to suspect that
North Koreans are misusing the
opportunity for immigration or asylum or
refugee status in the United States or
committing acts of terror and by the way
how many North Koreans are even flying
out of North Korea and coming to the
United States this is the most ludicrous
version of the travel ban yet
well Iraq and Sudan are now gone from
the list so I guess we figured out what
the hell was going on there but as you
mentioned now we have Venezuela North
Korea on list I think they're just
gimmies because this whole time the
Trump administration has been trying to
argue that is not a Muslim ban as he
referred to it as during the campaign
but he that that argument really never
stood its ground because they would look
at his past tweets in his past comments
his past declarations and that all
weighed into the court cases yeah I
think that this is very carefully
crafted to try to get around the main
arguments that legally make this dubious
by just adding some non Muslim countries
that's that's certainly part of it but
then consider Chad for example Chad is
roughly half Muslim Chad has been added
to the list Chad is a counterterrorism
ally of the United States chad is a
counterterrorism ally of our close ally
France why is Chad on the list at least
according to the Trump administration
it's because of their quote failure to
share Public Safety and terrorism
related information totally arbitrary
I mean experts say there is
no evidence that chad is even remotely
unique in not having the exact same
information sharing customs that the
u.s. might want its arbitrarily punitive
in every sense of the word and if you
believe in these lists again
Saudi Arabia should be on the list
instead Donald Trump is selling them
even more weapons but we always have to
step back with every version of this of
this ban I have said let's step back
what is the big picture will this keep
us safer at this point how can anybody
argue that it would this has become a
personal vendetta for Donald Trump it's
become a desperate attempt to sort of
check off a campaign promise because
still were more than eight months in now
right we are at the end of September
there have been no I mean zero major
policy accomplishments period for Donald
Trump and this is a punish countries I
don't like while simultaneously trying
to check off one of my campaign promises
effort and it's transparent and
pathetically so the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership